what's your number to have an x-rated
only fans account like a cost yeah
what's next i never never there's no
cost there's no price
the amount you can make with doing the
pg content that's just fine with me have
you thought about the amount you could
make okay let's let's do this let's do
this let's do this right now a million
dollars in your bank account if you do
an x-rated post yes or no okay five
million would you interesting show your
chance for a million dollars no i don't
think so not at this age maybe if i was
like if i had like a million kids and i
needed to like i was like dying but like
i don't need it right now since i love
like this job so much i don't think so
but if i didn't have a job and that's
all i had like if barclay's like you're
fired you can never get a job gonna be
like fine okay you know what i mean so
no number yeah you have to be in the
scarcity mentality or i'd have to like
take this sex worker route to want to do
that you need to put food on the table
yeah yeah and then you're gonna go big
yeah how about you no number oh i'm not
a very high number yeah
that's always been my thing though i'm
like yeah it's not that like true